this week on forward zach and i discuss
amazon's labor unions roe v wade student
loans and if you should blow your money
on a wedding this week on fortworth
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back jules we are back
how are you i'm great how are you i'm
pretty good before we dive in we've had
some changes in the pod and no one's
really we've never really talked about
it maybe i'll start like with some high
level but love your thoughts too what
we'd like to do is broaden and we've
kind of touched on this a bit like
broaden out
what
andrew stands for into a more of a media
company so um
loving having you on because i think
you're uh
definitely smarter than me on this stuff
but um but it's also a hell it's like a
new perspective too which i really enjoy
so
um we haven't figured out the cadence
yet so you guys have noticed you've had
andrew on with me andrew on with jules
zack on with jules jules on with someone
else i know i know we we're never really
discreet about it we haven't told you
what the heck to expect but i hope
i hope you like tune in like hey this is
interesting if it's not it'll be a
little different next week so keep
tuning in and you guys have been like
number has been pretty solid so thank
you actually uh jules rate's better than
everybody so thanks for oh really yeah
well at least on the youtube comment
section so i don't know how fickle that
is glad to be back again
um
we're talking about a bunch of stuff
today we talked about a whole bunch of
things yeah well yeah to your point
because i'm use i'm typically used to
short form content like that's my thing
so i feel like i'm finally getting
comfortable with the more long-form
podcast does it bother you that we have
to dive deeper on stuff that you can't
just like make your point
hot take get off the thing with me like
it's like i love curating information
and i'm like super nitpicky about it so
after after podcast a lot of the time
it's so easy for me to be like oh like i
wish i would have said this differently
or i didn't mean to say it like this
it's so easy to like get in your head
with long form content but i'm getting
used to it also it's just like uh yeah
with digital footprints and everything
too it's like because it's not only like
oh you me and you talking about
something it's now like the public
opinion is in on it too and like there's
all like these
compounding factors now when something
goes online that you're like oh crap you
think about it more when it's not like
as curated because on tick tock i have
short form contents like two to three
minutes and yeah i do research i do
writing before and then i record once i
like feel super confident in it and i i
press post myself and it goes out that
way so
there's just a lot more of like the
nitty-gritty details that you get into
but
that's the beauty about podcast too i
think like a lot of people it's crazy to
me when people take out of context clips
from long form podcasts because oh yeah
and also if you're sitting down talking
for hours on end every single week it's
like
yeah people are perfect it's real time
stuff if you had a mic in on like
conversations with your friends that
you're bound to say some some weird
stuff sometimes so but i'm getting used
to it and it's been it's been good
someone said this to me about joe rogan
they're like oh yeah of course he said
something racist he said infinity things
yeah he's been talking hours and hours
for what now that's not that doesn't
excuse me bad behavior but like
he said everything right so there's
gonna be stuff that maybe is is not
great um and he and like he apologized
for some of things he said and should
have um but also
i think
you know it's not a we're not a public
panel i mean we are i mean operationally
i guess but you're not like it's not
formal comments it is supposed to be raw
and real and so one of the things we
learned on the on when andrew's running
for mayor they were like combing over
our podcast episode 100 and
what was nice though is that i mean they
hammered us a couple things but
generally they they backed off
particularly on me because andrea said a
bunch of things but like who's this guy
right um
because
they got a sense after listening to
hours and hours of me talking that i'm i
didn't think i was a fundamental [ __ ]
which was nice so thank you uh folks for
uh
frankly giving us the ability to air
stuff out and actually today i want to
have
there are two topics i want to talk a
bunch of topics but there's two topics i
think um
i think the country deserves a real
nuanced rational conversation on and as
to unions and abortion which like
other union's pretty polarizing too and
abortion i don't think you find anything
more polarizing particularly at this
moment so i've been keeping up with the
whole amazon union situation over the
past few weeks months and i recently
started following chris smalls on
twitter and he's just like
he's like awesome like just just keeping
up with what he's doing also just like
literally
has been
this is going to go down in like history
books legitimately and it was crazy to
me like doing more research about this
and at one point the amazon's chief
counsel described mr smalls as not smart
or articulate in an email that
mistakenly went out to more than a
thousand people within amazon this week
he spoke in front of the senate budget
committee about like yeah um
how tax taxpayer dollars should not go
to companies that violate labor laws and
everything like that right he's spoken
from them so articulate so great so what
what was that probably rooted in some bs
either racism or dismisses decisiveness
um but can you summarize this situation
for those who
um i think maybe people are not familiar
with chris by name chris smalls by name
but maybe you're aware that there's an
amazon union fight that was um made some
news yeah so
he's amazon's labor unions
the president right now and it was uh
the first union in america for amazon i
think amazon in general elected just
across the world the first successful
one there's been a few efforts and close
to homes in staten island because we're
in new york city right now um so yeah he
won the first successful unionization
effort at amazon
and
it's one of the most significant labor
victories in a generation it's huge and
he's sad that there haven't been that
many but yeah and it's i was reading an
article i didn't realize uh i don't know
if it was him exactly but people within
um trying to build up this union had
utilized like yeah platforms like tick
tock to get the word out to other amazon
employees and everything like that so
it's just been fascinating to keep along
with and of course you know amazon's
trying to has been trying to block it
and everything like that and speaking
against it but yeah this week he spoke
in front of the senate budget committee
he met with president biden and there
was like a lot of videos on that and
just cool yeah he's he's doing great
even when he's he went on fox news and
he's super just like
balanced and chill with everything he
like people are trying to kind of hit
him with these questions that the
gotchas yeah the gotcha questions and
he's he's not giving into it and he's
being very straightforward it's really
cool to watch he did this
so
to me
um
it's fascinating to me because he didn't
do it the way most the other union
efforts have failed would i get a
polarizing congressman or woman
they drum up freak out press there's all
the hype and hoopla
he just kind of organized a quiet
walkout this community yeah
and then amazon's like oh wait this
sucks and like now our factory's not
working like now we'll come to the table
because you're clearly in it for
uh
for the it's uh he's clearly in it for
the right reasons right and i think his
quote which we were sharing as a team is
like it's not it's not a left thing it's
not a right thing this is just a people
thing yes and it was very i was like uh
hey andrew yang here we go um yeah so i
wanted to ask you about
i think it's time we have a bit of a
nuanced conversation on unions because i
think what bothered me on the
presidential campaign in particular or
as soon as i got into politics was you
want to be like we're pro union right
and it's like black or black or white
issue or it's like if i'm pro union i'm
pro people i'm pro good paying jobs i'm
pro the little man the university it's
hard to like refute that right it's hard
to be like
let's say maybe i don't like unions in
all cases then i like hate people i'm
pro like people exploiting workers and
laborers and
i don't like hard work like that i want
to rip apart families and i don't like
people have pensions like and
there's truth on both but i want to say
there's there's a nuance because i would
say particularly for someone who lives
in new york city like i think the
teachers union here was really
destructive during covid and i have
teachers i love who are really i have
like that like their union where they
are so there there's nuance here so i'll
start with this by virtue signaling i am
pro-people so generally like the spirit
of unions i'm generally for i just don't
think they're always great in practice
yeah um and i'll get into that but my
question is
in your maybe i always ask you to speak
for the younger generation which is not
fair on you so maybe just give your
opinion and yeah
um have you seen you know that your
friends or other
like gen the gen z world or maybe when
you're in high school is
do they are they aware of unions in
general do they have opinions on this or
this is just like right over their head
like i would say it was very much over
my head until recently because i mean
i've always the past well not always
just the past three to four years have
been interested what's going on within
amazon warehouses just like there were
all those different articles we've got
people peeing bottles they felt like
they didn't have enough time right for
their productivity to go to the bathroom
it was like different stories you're
hearing awful whether they're true or
not
unclear i guess but the story seemed
pretty bad yeah so and i totally get
that point of like if you have these
productivity goals that you need to meet
so that you don't get fired they're like
yes they're not saying you can't go to
the bathroom but just this external
pressure and like it carries over so
i to be honest like i don't have
extensive knowledge into the history of
unions and everything like that but like
specifically within amazon it's been
fascinating to me and yeah i would say
like within our generation it hasn't
been because unions haven't been much of
a conversation the past decade yeah
they've been losing so it's it just
hasn't really been something that's been
culturally relevant or whatever so but
now it seems to be piping up a whole
labor movement so very so
so here's how i land on this and i think
it's what i want to talk about that so
on from the entrepreneurial side
someone took a risk
to build a company right man or woman
they took all the rest they put it all
on black and then they had to hire
people to help them achieve that vision
and they pay folks a wage to do it right
the hardest part of that is the initial
investment right the initial risk and
that sort of thing and getting people
you want to reward people that are
creating literally the definition of
making money they're creating money and
opportunity like they're making one plus
one equal three like that's the stuff
that drives
frankly humanity in many ways but we
also have to make sure we don't exploit
individuals like if there are folks that
have no other opportunity to make a
living to survive so they have to work
in these exploited jobs and then the
person who took the risk yes they
deserve to be rewarded for that risk but
they shouldn't be creating slave labor
right they shouldn't be doing things
they shouldn't be abusing people and
that's the balance right so these folks
workers should be safe and paid fair and
feeling good the problem is
there comes a point sometimes where the
person who took that risk and built this
and then the union can show up sometimes
with the best intentions sometimes not
where they make the company frankly
uncompetitive or no longer existing and
that kind of defeats the purpose in ways
look people have different opinions
particularly in europe about the role of
a job and um but if we're a capitalist
country we like to compete in that level
and i think you have to find these
nuances i think the government boring
union jobs i'm a little more okay with
because it should be more of a
like standard so one of my best friends
uh growing up his dad worked in the
union he said you get these young whiz
kids coming in but it wouldn't matter
i'd get paid more and i would have to
work less because i'd been there longer
it was all about seniority
that doesn't help in a capitalistic
society right it doesn't help companies
innovate it doesn't help the consumer
usually right but in a government
i don't love that but i can see an
argument for like this is like a job
program program or something like that
but you also have a world where unions
can be really destructive where they're
they were focused on the teachers more
than they were the kids uh or you look
at campaigns whether it's like it's a
campaign it's a temporary organization
and you had the bernie campaign the
warren campaign a lot of them were the
you the workers are trying to unionize
and i understand like workers should be
heard and they should have rights to be
paid fair
but guys
we're all sprinting on a campaign this
is not an organization that's going to
exist more than a year half a year right
the point of unionizing all the work
that goes into it when the
organization's gonna die soon doesn't
make any sense so i feel like the i
guess that's my tirade on like unions
for union's sake doesn't make sense um
because it becomes more of a virtue
signal
but unions to actually protect workers
and create a a great working
relationship between a company and it's
like the people that make it run that's
what it should be you know what i'm
saying and i feel like chris smalls
frankly to me nails that yeah he's like
i like this job generally speaking we
got some problems but we want to work
here we won't be paid well we don't want
amazon to go under but we want to we
want to thrive but we want to not be
exploited am i making any sense that
made complete sense and
to everything online i mean
just messaging in general it's easy to
do the black or white take of go this
way because just grouping everything
together like this is always good yeah
yeah
that's not fair yeah i think that's jeff
bezos is always evil
not fair because
i'm watching the show out of range right
now thank you jeff bezos he funded the
expanse like that show i get my shipping
for free love that you know what i'm
saying like there's right now we have to
find the balance um
and i like theoretically if this
argument takes takes place behind closed
doors within amazon and they get to a
solution instead of
on aoc's twitter
and the public charade it's probably
more productive
yeah i mean but there definitely seems
to be some internal bias within amazon
and also just when when you are super
high up like regard like regardless
you're just you know you're uh
a little out of touch with certain
realities especially of the warehouse
workers so
in a way it's like public opinion is a
complete mess but also it it definitely
does help push those things so it's all
a double-edged sword and it's nothing is
black or white regard like every aspect
of everything in life is not black
you've got bezos as a trillionaire and
you get your workers working for peanuts
like guys that's awful right like but um
what's the butt like bezos built this
right it is you know generally his or
the public and it what does amazon do it
makes money that's what it is intended
for and um so i shouldn't exploit people
but um i'm a big believer i think warren
was in favor of this was uh putting
union representation on the board and
having to be owners um that to me makes
a lot of sense um especially if you're
amazon you're that big you've created
that much wealth like you should be
sharing it with the workers that doesn't
mean they have to they should run the
company like i don't think that
equations but like yeah like these i'm
always for the little incentives it
doesn't have to be like percentages of
like you know when the company meets
certain goals or whatever it is like
yeah it's just like it's a group effort
it's a community effort like we we all
win together like yeah just little
bonuses when the company wins it's like
that's that type of stuff is really
attractive to me that's the other thing
if you're working for nothing
or for cheap right you're putting in the
sweat equity you want to share in the
upside yes that's how startups work
right like okay you're gonna underpay me
here but i get a piece of equity so if i
work and it grows i get a piece of the
pie and i got the pie bigger unions are
so personal and they're so in my opinion
case by case like union for one industry
should is is not should be is different
than union for another industry like
unions and campaigns don't make any
sense yeah does that mean workers
shouldn't have a voice no are there
other ways to give the workers a voice
yes so we should explore that right so i
think i think when it comes to unions
probably most things you could say but
there's not this we just need to
remember it's not black and white
[Music]
[Music]
want to talk to you guys about a new
sponsor we have called air table and if
you've ever tried to do any sort of
leadership activity or startup you have
seen airtable at least be offered to you
as an awesome solution in this ever
changing landscape of work how can you
ensure your people workflows and data
stay connected airtable is how airtable
allows you to create flexible systems
that help your team operate as one i've
used it a few times different orgs and
it's fantastic so break down the
barriers that leave teams feeling
disconnected with airtable your team
works from a single source of truth that
is always up to date and keeps everyone
on the same page so with their adaptable
approach everyone from marketers to
product teams to podcast producers can
build tools that fit uniquely to the way
they work plus airtable keeps individual
projects connected to your higher level
goals so you never lose sight of what
you're working toward it's pretty
awesome so give it a try for free at
airtable.com today that's
airtable.com to get started for free
check it out guys a massively helpful
tool
all right so the supreme court has shot
down
the long-standing law of the land
precedent of roe v wade which made
access to abortions legal in the united
states of america it was abortion was a
constitutional right
it has now shot it down
uh
making abortion up to the states
essentially yep not protected by the
federal constitution
what does that mean in practice y'all
your conservative states are going to
outlaw it
however whatever outlaw think it's
estimated like 25. your liberal states
will probably
do everything they can go the other way
if they haven't already i'm like i'm a
moderate if you will um but this is
something i'm
and i'm i grew up a christian i don't i
don't particularly and it doesn't matter
what i think but you know just for
context i'm not like morally
thinking abortion's the greatest thing
in the world
but the right to an abortion
is something that um
i think is fundamental and
in a modern day society no country has
ever
ever taken itself out of poverty without
giving access to abortions to women and
access to real birth control and and
family planning resources to women
the majority of americans agree with me
yeah the majority of republic is a good
chunk of republicans that agree with me
so this is now so this is why and andrew
wanted to say this i'm going to say it's
like i feel like democrats owe this
country an apology
for
freaking losing in so many ways over the
past let's call it 20 years because this
is where
presidential elections matter
or not being able to do anything in
congress matters because they could have
codified this into law i mean there's
kind of almost like no words for it it's
pretty wild it does feel like we're
going back decades and decades to me
it's like
i don't think i
would ever do so except maybe when i was
in high school and maybe you would were
to make a stupid decision or like
whatever having that option would have
been so important for me personally
i i probably would not go through with
an abortion but i yes 100 respect that
right for other people also and should
never ever be questioned in terms of
like rape incest all those different
things that should never be a question
of people having to carry through with
that
and
so i mean it's just insane to me and i i
think a lot of um conservatives are
talking about well it's just giving
power back to the states okay
half of the states 25 states are going
would immediately put that into action
and it's it's just not conversation to
me and it's like if you are for that you
better be for rooting for like the
foster care system in terms of like all
the resources there everything like that
like it just seems like this weird thing
online of um
you know life all this stuff and it's
the conversation seems to stop there
then it's it's never it never goes
further into child care and yeah into
foster care and everything like that
like
i should see you advocating for that
stuff all the time especially in this
time i haven't seen like a single tweet
about that it's just like a signaling
thing of it it's really crazy and what's
also really scary is in um a few of
these states is plan b
which is a contraceptive method yeah
would also um be threatened and i think
it's like five or six of these states
and plan b all it does is not like to
say all it does but it blocks
fertilization so it's before
anything's like conceived or anything
like that
this thing that could be blocked in
states that and that gets really in a
weird snowball effect if you have that
birth control everything like that and
that's a whole nother conversation i
think more guys that
i'm going to say more guys that look
like me need to say more about this
because the women are saying doing what
they can generally speaking so here's
what i'll say there's an argument you
may know but but the reality is like
these laws don't make any sense because
they don't actually ban abortion they
ban abortion for poor people because
rich people always get abortion what
happened to rich people in a southern
state that has abortions ban a couple
things happen
generally speaking uh one is that
they're already super rich and so the 16
year old who gets pregnant marries their
high school sweetheart and they make it
work because they have money and support
and a system around them and they're
this poster child for why you shouldn't
ever abort anything yeah okay fine but
the other ones they they go out of state
and get an abortion without telling
anybody that's the other situation but
that's not what we're talking about
that's not the problem the problem is
for
folks that are on the the bottom of the
economic ladder and either make a
mistake or they they don't they don't
there's not like a let's call family
planning education they don't really
understand the cycle of poverty that
continuing to have more babies is
putting them in
and
the hypocrisy is what kills me the
hypocrisy is so ridiculous because you
say you're pro-life
so we force you to take pregnancy to
term which okay i get it cool this is
our gig right but if you are
pro-life then we should also be pro like
strong health care and family planning
and paid maternity leave and a great
social safety net so that the mothers
that take their baby to term can't have
a positive life for the child but
instead we say we're pro-life and then
[ __ ] you
good luck take care of that kid and then
we [ __ ] when crime goes up and if
anyone ever read freakonomics the first
one uh talked about like why crime went
down was what like there was a direct
correlation after crime after roe v wade
was implemented and crime let's call it
18 years later 18 strong families you
have stronger families you have less
kids being born out of wedlock and in
tougher family situations it's a real
thing so
i think
a couple things my republican friends
that listen to this they talk about the
morality of this which i understand um
but there's a difference between
what you believe is morally right and
what makes good policy and i think we
got to remember that nuance like i'm not
morally
for people like
smoking marijuana in public or driving
vehicles or
uh various drugs and things like that
but
like the policy-wise makes sense to
legalize it for a number of different
reasons right you go down the list of
what
the difference be moral and what makes
good policy i don't see any really
evidence at all that that's good
economic or social policy to be banning
abortions i will say this to my left
friends on the left the argument my body
my choice is not resonating with the
right yeah uh for a number of reasons
one if it's your body you don't have the
right to murder people so if they
believe it's murder that's not a good
argument but two
what happened to my body my choice when
we were putting up mask mandates like
like obviously different than abortion
okay but like
we can't have our own hypocrisy and
point out their hypocrisy right let me
ask you this the best analogy someone
told me about the carly told me this on
abortion is not um because a lot of the
the concept of life beginning at
conception right
they said to me this if you're because
if you argue that a fetus
and an actual born child are equal
then abortion is murder right um but if
you said
okay we're in a burning building right
now and there's a six-year-old girl
or an infant um let's say it's
six-year-old girl
and a tower of a hundred
fertilized eggs
and you can only grab one
and the building is burning which one do
you grab yeah you take the child right
so you and you let the and so did you
murder a hundred uh fetuses not i don't
think that's a equivalent right i think
most people would save the child because
of a number of reasons so
that's the way i think we need to look
at it and then have an honest
conversation about abortion but we're
not and that's my rant i've had two
rants today that's my rant no these are
powerful no i i don't know what you
think no i 100 agree with all that i
don't have much ad because i think you
hit every
every point that you possibly could so
yeah just people need to you know
assess all angles that could first of
all come at their point and also just
like all angles ever just culture and
yeah the long the long-term effects of
everything too
um there's you people need to dive
deeper into just saying these blatant
statements that are really actually
contradicting of each other that's right
if you want to be a republican and say
i'm pro-life
you can't also be pro-small government
yeah you know what i'm saying because
that's where we're getting into trouble
that's where it's bad policy we're just
like forcing women to have babies and
then we're throwing them the wolves and
some may say i don't care you go to hell
because you're saying that and i don't
um i think that's a cop-out i think we
need to have real conversations on it
we're both in the same campus this isn't
like a deep debate but yeah um i do
understand this it's emotionally charged
yeah and i apologize to anyone that i um
have triggered by this and i would love
your comments if you can be nice in the
in the youtube comment section i see
more mending to say something it's dark
it's really dark um and so so here's
silver lining hopefully democrats show
up to vote
in 2022 and 2024 because of this
um i guess right like a
is that the silver lining i don't know
it's just wild
because this is what happens when you
lose elections democrats
now congress should solve this and they
could pass a law they could do this the
supreme court is like you know whether
they're accurate or not that's really
not the point the point is we need to do
something
let's talk about student loans a little
less polarizing
yeah
it's so kind of polarizing i guess well
it's i don't think it's a polarizing
issue i think this is actually something
that is more
it feels more nuanced a little bit like
there's a lot of different angles people
can take and it kind of it doesn't
necessarily seem it's a a black or white
thing so there are kind of three
situations right now that are on the
table
because of course one of biden's biggest
promises was tackling the student loan
issue
and
or you know it was was it it was a big
promise that the
young
folks particularly on the left grabbed
onto right were they like biden's on
board with our
i'm i remember that being his like yeah
most prominent messaging towards young
people yeah like that yes there's three
things on the table either binding
cancels up to 10k binding cancels
between 10k and 50k which is a big range
but in terms of people's student loans
not necessarily like too big of a range
um and by the third biden cancels all
student debt for everyone or for
borrower borrowers with over 50k when it
comes to this though there's going to be
if if this any of this happens income
limits so if you are a single person it
is if if you earned less than 150 000
per year um and if you are in a couple
like uh
file your taxes jointly it would be
under 250k that you bring in per year is
who these things would apply to it's
it's very interesting so full disclosure
i have student loans i think i have just
a little bit under the like um average
in america of what the average student
has what's the average 45k 100. i think
i was like 30 something okay i don't
know i could be wrong there i'm assuming
it's around 30.
oh yeah
what is the average and how much below
the average are you
so when it comes to this an interesting
conversation that i see a lot even
within my relatives is like you know if
you took out student loans you knew what
you were doing you pay them
it's such an interesting
conversation because like we talked
about one of our first episodes together
kids don't even know like what they want
to do when they get into college it's
just the cultural next step when you
leave high school and yeah and so so
many kids i think it's again like 70 of
people end up changing their major at
least once we've already talked about
this so to think in my situation and not
to like it's just like you don't
understand what loans were you didn't
learn that in high in high school i did
not have any required personal finance
classes i ended up taking a personal
finance class but we did not cover
anything regarding that you want to go
to a college where you feel like you are
getting a decent education i went to the
college that i got the most scholarship
money at but still need to take out
student loans you just don't understand
the concept of money fully at that age
you only maybe had some yeah minimum
wage jobs mine paid like seven dollars
an hour the concept of
tens of thousands of dollars it's like
you can't even understand that like
genuinely you just don't understand and
you're like i just need to go to college
and this is what's going to set me up
for the future as well
it's
it sounds weird but like when you think
of it from the major perspective it's
the same type of situation of like
you're just blinded by all these
different things and you just go into it
and then you leave college you're like
oh my gosh i now understand being an
adult how much money that is right and
how much college has gone up by in terms
of like percentages and whatever has not
by any means matched inflation over the
past decades it has far exceeded that
like it's fake market yeah so
there's a lot of different angles but
that's a that's a point that really
bothers me of
like oh you knew what you were getting
into there's also the point of you know
other people have paid their loans i
think that's just like a weak
argument of like you want everyone to
suffer yet sucks and like it sucks that
i i feel that way too of over the past
what two years when how student loans
have been paused i was like oh should i
keep paying them i'm like actually
i'm going to pause because what if
something does happen i would yes regret
paying him i know that would suck if i
was paying these past two years and it
kind of gets washed i'd be like oh my
god i spent thousands over the past two
years paying them without um yep yeah
interest rates and what not so i
understand that feeling and it sucks we
have to to put it on other people of
like
just because yeah
yeah it's
it's wild yeah and then there's the
other other big ones like there's a lot
of people that didn't go to college
like you're almost in a way punishing
or not even punishing let's say not
rewarding those who made let's call it
the financially prudent decision
theoretically i said look i can't afford
college i'm not going to go or they went
like the cheaper route they took night
classes and did things like that
which is it's a fair argument um the
other argument on the pro is that you
know you'd unlock
theoretically a whole generation or it's
not a whole generation it's about what
30 percent of american adults over 18
that have gone to college a lot of folks
are
a lot of people with the most student
loans are past their 30s by the numbers
so it isn't going to be as big of a boon
as you think but it is taking the boot
off a lot of people's throat
um it is kind of ending a ridiculous
system here's my point and i've heard
folks talk about this scott galloway has
talked about it they talked about this
on all in podcasts as well
is
i'm i'm in favor of this theoretically
as long as they solve the problem going
forward yes you know what i'm saying
where if we just cancel all student debt
right now
what are you doing in the future so one
you now you know in some ways injected a
whole bunch of capital into the economy
and we have an inflation market so maybe
not great i'm not an economist i don't
particularly know but here's the other
piece is so anybody else who goes to
college they go for free like what's the
solution there
and the issue with this stuff is at that
at the root of it is a skills matching
problem
if someone said i don't like you're an
18 year old you don't know what you want
to go go to college for what's your
message do what you love so these kids
are going to
wildly expensive schools and they're
majoring in either
like the two problematic major
categories to me are like something like
a passion major like the arts or um
something that isn't going to pay a lot
coming out like a philosophy or
something yes and there's nothing um
particularly wrong with those fields of
study except that there's not a lot of
jobs and that pay very well so you now
spend a lot of money to have with
minimal earning potential off that
degree
and the second one is it's too broad
like uh
it sounds cool it's like business
administration but it's not maybe like
specialized enough for your path
basically
like you you're telling kids like go go
do this unemployable career path and
we're going to get put you in like 200
grand worth of debt and good luck paying
it off and so that to me is
unsustainable
do we have an engineer shortage in this
country probably yes um do we have a
medical certain doctor shortage
particularly in rural parts of america
yes like that's where we should be
paying people to go to college and learn
that advanced degree um we have a
trade shortage we should be sending
people to free trade school in certain
parts of the country and certain types
of people that so if there's a plan
there that the me makes sense again this
is one of the things it sounds so good
then you like pull back the onion just
and that's so frustrating
we're not talking like we're not experts
in this per se we're just feeling like
one layer these are just yeah like one
step bro parts of the thought process
iterations in the thought process we're
not like seeing ask one follow-up
question and it gets complicated when
this first kind of broke of president
biden just told a group of lawmakers
he's looking at different options to
forgive most if not all federal student
loan debt i did a quote tweet and to
your point of okay what happens to
education after this because the cost
problem still remains i was like yeah
this feels like it could be a breaking
point for higher education we already
see so many people assessing
their next steps after high school
because of these cost things so the cost
will still remain the government won't
be doing this every x amount of years
because at that point why not make
college free obviously like what are you
paying for and families will feel the
moral duty to have their kids consider
other options before the pandemic and
you know this is something we already
talked about that's
kind of something that is good that came
from the pandemic is people assessing
gap years and everything like that but
before the pandemic and yet even when i
first graduated high school was still
like a lot of pressure of the next step
so
just it's going to become
much more normal for parents to
like
assess this for their kids and this is
something i've argued often i used to
make tick tock content about how
high school and everything like that
should have yeah financial literacy
courses that are required i know some
schools do but it is not a requirement
across the country the only problem with
that is
again kids have no grasp on
real world experiences so it just
becomes another class where you remember
stuff for a test and then it flies out
the window for financial literacy yes
even that because you you've never dealt
with money yourself before so it becomes
weird there and this is a problem i have
with the greater education system in
general is that there needs to be more
experiential learning yes that's that's
very easy statement to say obviously and
kids can't necessarily go into yeah
internships there's not enough
internships and then it would there be
an issue of not unpaid internships all
this different stuff maybe they could
get high school credits for it whatever
but to me
what
schools need to be doing and a role
teachers can really play is being great
curators of content and information
right now so much of the content they
get is from yes textbooks how kids like
to learn is through like their favorite
youtube creators and everything like
that it's like
there's so many amazing yeah financial
youtubers that like teachers can
pull from it starts with that it gets
these kids really engaged in terms of
learning from someone that they directly
respect their financial situation they
see the real world application through
these videos and then textbook learning
supports that because it's like
they saw a real world experience of
someone they respect even though they
didn't like live through it they are
vicariously living through it and then
the textbook
information actually becomes interesting
and applicable to their real lives
because right now if you just go
textbook to test again you're just
learning for the test and it goes out
the window correct so there just needs
there's needs to be kind of an uphold in
the education system right now because
kids are not interested in how they are
learning information at all it's so it's
it's active learning right so yeah this
is my non-profit suit up for you
oh yes you know this too well yeah
teaching kids like math you say like no
we're going to create a new shoe for
nike and you're going to have to use
math to figure out what it costs right
they need that they're like and then you
can see kids like
a light bulb goes off but i'll tell you
what when we started doing this
i thought
this is what edu like teachers should be
doing yes
and i and i can't tell you how many
teachers and students are like i've
never learned i never thought of this
i've never done i've never realized why
i'm learning
creative writing or math i feel so dumb
for mansplaining that to you you were
like the picture like you know the
greatest question for anybody else and
it was nice to hear you talk about it
because it's true and here's the problem
though it's like
it's and andrew is talking about this on
the trail at times she's like a good a
good teacher is worth their weight in
gold and like
the problem is we're talking about scale
right um so
private schools frankly the parents are
paying out to ask for xy like for great
teachers and so these great teachers
have and they and they inherently get
curriculum flexibility so they can craft
these lessons to teach the kid but at
scale or dub a public school you end up
having this like to prevent people from
going off the rails you end up having
like
structure or the curriculum almost like
an industrial assembly line right and
it's like this is the math curriculum
teach it make sure they get it right and
you know at scale you'd rather have them
learning to add than
learning what nike is you know
theoretically um
it's hard reality is like education is
more of an art than a science and so you
want the solution is to have great
teachers and to get there you have to
pay them a lot exactly
so all right what's one thing getting
you excited though what's one thing to
be happy about
this this was a it's not necessarily
something you're excited about but i
found it very interesting that broke
today it was very nostalgic a little a
little bit like not triggering but uh
the ipod got discontinued today
the ipod ipod the ipod the oh gee i've
gone i thought it's been gone but like
they still selling at the staff i don't
know i'm assuming just on the website
yeah i thought it's i don't know i
always assume it's ping pong but like
that seeing that news today i was like
actually that kind of like no more ipods
yeah because that was like
the black market for this or the
secondary market goes up you won't buy
an ipod i have like my old ones like
those thick like the pink ones like
kids they will never understand the and
appreciate the awesomeness of that ipod
like the first color ipod screen was
like oh my god yeah now they're going to
have the instagram nfts that that also
does rip i'd say i'm excited i i'm doing
wedding planning
i got engaged i know that's crazy like
tell the back story like where where
would it end up being how long we're
going to play that's what we're going to
do gentlemen keep up okay i engaged for
those you've never met carly she was our
finest director on the presidential
she's great you probably got a bunch of
angry emails from carly if you ever
donated to presidential
the inside joke on the campaign was
carly was like i'm not liking what i'm
seeing uh would be a common subject line
she loves scavenger hunts she did a
scavenger hunt one time and i love that
like nerded out she's a nerd like have
you ever listened she has a podcast
called overpriced jpegs on nfts i don't
understand any of that stuff
so i was like it'd be fun to do a
scavenger hunt so i did a scavenger hunt
where
every stop on this tour she would
ideally um should meet up with friends
from all over the country that she
hadn't seen in a while like
new york um which is luck unfortunately
like she's a very good friend so her
friends were like i'm willing to fly out
i didn't have to pay for their flights
so thank you wow yeah she got out of bed
and like she like i left and uh
she woke up and got a clue at the door
and then she went to her favorite coffee
shop and her best friend was there and
then the barista gave him
like anticipating that stuff was
happening this day at all or she like
woke up and you were like scavenger hunt
so yeah it was actually a disaster where
um best laid plans if you ever do
proposal it's um
it never goes the way you wanted to
ideally that's the fun part so she was
doing this last minute trip she's so
freaking smart so she was like
uh she had planned it last minute to be
the weekend i had been planning and
there's a lot of moving parts like her
mom's in town and
uncle's in town all of her friends are
flying she's like i'm coming back
i propose on the 30th that she was
coming back i come back may 1st and i
was like
no you're not like you you're not doing
that
um
and i was like and my cover for this
event was that we had a our friends were
having a fundraiser party that day um so
i was trying to keep it cash but i was
like
what about their fundraiser and she's
like why do you care so much about that
fundraising i don't know it's like why
would you possibly oh my god you're
proposing that weekend that's what she
said to me i was like oh my god
oh my god no no i'm not
so she kind of knew but she didn't know
what um
but she cut her trip early thank god but
because she was on like trip time or
wherever she was up at seven in the
morning
and her first clue was at her favorite
coffee shop
and so she's up at seven in the morning
and wants to go get to the coffee shop
and i'm like oh my god no that's awful
um so i like it basically distracted her
with gilmore girls her favorite show and
i was like we'll just watch it and
sit in front of the tv it was awful that
was awful but eventually you got that so
she met her best friend at the coffee
shop and then we went to she went to
each one was like a clue she had to find
it and then
went to oritzia and saw all of her
college friends it was like her favorite
store and she got like a dress and then
we did a lunch at her normal campaign
spot where she used to eat ramen all the
time on the campaign and all the camp
like a number of campaign friends were
there
and then
she went down to a hotel i got a hotel
room and did like you know got her nails
done in champaign and listened to taylor
swift with her like hometown friends and
then i got
one of the actors from gilmore girls she
loves that show did like a cameo i tried
to get the actual gilmore girls
there rory you went all out this is like
very i did and then we met that we did
at the first place and she went to the
first place we ever met which was a
campaign event at the skinny bar which
is a dive bar but they were so much fun
they were like really fun to like set it
up and then all like friends and family
were there and we had like open bar so
wow i will say this guys have you ever
proposed um
it's a lot more nerve-wracking than i
ever thought i didn't think i'd be
nervous because like i knew she could
say yes we had talked about it and
you're like with her day in and day out
so it's like yo it's fine but that ring
burns a hole in your pocket
rings are a racket they're a racket um
i would recommend going to estate
jewelers you can get some good deals
there and so now i'm in the throes of
wedding planning because there's a lot
of backup
if you don't want to get married in like
three years you've got to kind of act
pretty fast because there's like a
backlog from covid
we are what size of the wedding
i want a huge wedding oh you do because
i just love people and like i don't know
okay i have to say no to people that i
like if you're gonna feed and
have a bar for 200 people
it's like 200 a pop like i don't it
doesn't like maybe in new york it's
probably more expensive in certain parts
to crunch a little expensive but it's
between 150 and 250 like
i don't know if someone you want to dm
me and find me like alternative so i've
i've decided we're either going to go
like
like a backyard barbecue and save all
the money i was going to say just or
just go all in you know um and just
either end of the spectrum not like you
know crazy wedding but like actually
just spend the money because it's worth
if you're going to do it do it just kind
of hybrid um now i'm not i have been
saving i've been like a good book for
y'all read this rich dad poor dad i'm a
big believer in like only spending money
you have to me right now i'm like i
would just want to get eloped or
something that seems like i i
would get anxious more on my wedding day
and if there was a ton of people so i'm
like oh i want to like enjoy it but
andrew schultz actually when he got
married recently he had a very
interesting instagram caption it was
like your wedding is like kind of the
last day that all your loved ones will
be in the same room and i was like oh my
gosh like it's kind of like the one time
in your life it's not the only time yeah
like really think about it like i'm
looking at i got college friends high
school friends campaign friends and then
carly's got a similar like we overlap in
the campaign which is cool but the new
york friend like and then your family's
there too it is i was like this is going
to be really cool like if you get if we
do a really good job it'll be wonderful
i don't want to say it's a racket the
rings are a real racket but it's a lot
it's
it's bad it's uh because i was looking
at someone like trying to find like
like discount like cheaper venues
it's the same
you say a little bit on the venue cost
we still gotta feed everybody and you
gotta have a bar i think i don't i mean
some people do cash bars like to use
their own but like i don't know people
are going to come all the way out to
your wedding
let's uh let's get the government to
target wedding venues that's yeah that's
the real subsidies you know hey if you
i actually like there's like pro-family
policies
and stay married for x number of years
let's call it 20 years
like you get um
or it's like you get the money up front
and you don't have to pay it back the
longer you're together i'm laughing but
actually we kind of need that now we
could use that um some of the some of
the like photos we took the engagement
photos are like they don't look like
engagement photos it looks like we're
dropping like a new startup we look like
really
like an ambitious couple
i put some on instagram and put them all
up i guess i'll drop them over time okay
cool thanks everyone
guys thank you for joining ladies guys
everybody we love you tune in monday
andrew will be back
[Music]
you